des indicateurs toujours préoccupant la
métropole de dijon reste très proche du
basculement en zone alerte renforcée
le taux d'incidence a atteint 156 5
c'est le nombre de personnes contaminées
en sept jours sur cent mille habitants
les lits de réanimation de la région
sont de plus en plus occupés par des
patients qu'ovide 11 à dijon et 29 sur
l'ensemble de la bourgogne franche comté
il faut vraiment rester mobilisés pour
maintenir ce seuil à un niveau
acceptable qui évite de mettre le
système de santé en tension pour
permettre à la population d'avoir accès
à des soins pour dire pouce et il faut
que les gens puissent accéder au plateau
technique programme ont besoin c'est
important est d'autre part aussi pour
soulager la communauté médicale et
paramédicale des établissements de santé
qui ont été mis à dure épreuve et qui
sont honnêtement aujourd'hui encore
fatigué pour contrôler la situation une
seule nouvelle mesure annoncée ce samedi
à partir de lundi la vente d'alcool sera
interdite après 21h pour éviter les
rassemblements sur la voie publique
cette règle ne concerne pas encore les
bars et les restaurants
pour le préfet c'est un petit effort
pour éviter le pire
le message c'est que c'est le moment de
se mobiliser c'est le moment de se
responsabiliser d'avoir un comportement
civique pour éviter de contrarier la vie
économique et sociale de certains
secteurs d'activité aux ânes accru ses
propriétaires de deux épiceries près de
la gare il est directement concernée et
dénonce une incohérence la personne elle
peut s'asseoir boire deux trois bières
et elle pourra pas venir à mon acheté
chez moi c'est dommage donc en plus
c'est souvent des consommations qui sont
parfaites ni dehors mais qui sont faites
chez eux donc
donc moi ça je trouve c'est pas normal
au vu des indicateurs la foire
gastronomique de dijon va-t-elle être
maintenue l'organisateur dijon congrexpo
dénonce une prise de décision tardive
vécu comme un supplice réponse la
semaine prochaine